ich werfe dir nicht vor dass du bücher
interpretiert aber ich möchte dem autor
hier wirklich vorhalten dass er noch
nicht mal die interessanten fragen auf
das ist meine eigene leistung vielleicht
sind die bücher gemacht für menschen die
nicht so wahnsinnig intelligent und sie
finden
also nicht so kannst du dich daran
erinnern
unsere erste literatursendung von über
sieben jahren ich mach mal noch nachts
schweißgebadet auf da haben wir über der
circle gesprochen von dave eggers es ist
total glatt es ist total
lesbar es ist super gut gemacht aber es
ist auch sehr es ist nicht schlecht
sondern schlicht geschrieben das was
jetzt der verschiedene antworten wollen
es geht
darum was es mit dem menschen macht wenn
er sozusagen sich dauernd kurzschließt
mit apps und mit einer präsenz die nur
virtuell stattfindet was ist das buch
überhaupt so der roman bewirkt es als
thriller man kann auch sagen es ist eine
satire wally aus ja es ist das typisch
weil es einen blick in die zukunft wirft
wo ein ganz kleiner teil der bevölkerung
sich sozusagen drastisch verweigert und
der größte teil aber eben wie manische
schiffchen mit macht ich finde eben dass
es interessant in dem sinne
digitalisierung und künstliche
intelligenz in romanform behandelt zu
wissen weil das ist ein thema was mit
dem wir uns immer und tagtäglich
auseinandersetzen ich lese wahnsinnig
gerne diese romane weil die die all die
fragen die sich uns stellen noch mal in
eine andere ebene nämlich in unsere
lebensweltliche ebene transportieren und
mir nahe bringen das hat eben mit meiner
lebenswelt gar nichts zu tun sondern
dann wird total eingetaucht ist doch gut
wenn es mit seiner lebenswelt nichts es
ist dann an wenn sie es die das feld
visieren aber wenn sie das nicht
schaffen dann bringt mir das nicht ich
möchte mal einen anderen dreh machen
dieses buch ist wie ein produkt von
apple den fiktiven konzern und zwar
insbesondere dabei ist auch die art und
weise das ist das gefühl
irgendwie weg nun schon durch den konsum
trage ich zur weltverbesserung weil
dieses buch appelliert so an diese
instinkte jahr so kritik die ich immer
auch schon so dumpf empfunden habe die
die wird mir hier als tatsächlich gültig
und valide vorgeführt das gibt dem leser
ein gutes gefühl gibt ja so romane die
man die ist und man fühlt sich gut weil
sie so in wohlbefinden sich bewegen in
wohlgefallen das ist das eines ist aber
dass es dabei ziemlich ist aber schon
hier ist eine andere stufe von viel gut
dass es so ich habe recht das ist auch
sehr schön wenn du sowas liest und du
hast das ist eine haltung bestellen ja
die welt ist zwar eine desolate zustand
aber das habe ich übrigens auch schon
immer gesagt und hier erfahre ich habe
recht das ist eine noch viel eigentlich
perfide art des feelgood faktors als
jetzt bei so eskapistische literatur die
nicht einfach woanders hin führt so ist
die sache man wie so ein youtube
algorithmus der immer wieder das
vorschlägt dass eine mäh schon aus der
eigenen blase bestätigt also es ist doch
jetzt doch langweilig nicht gut
ich kann mich nicht entscheiden
also was hat das angebot schafft ja eben
nicht viel
man könnte auch sagen es ist er wie zwei
machen das gleiche buch das thema was
ist gesetzt hat sich damit zu befassen
dass wir in einer zeitenwende stehen und
wie gehen wir mit dieser kontrolle um
das fand ich damals sehr sehr
weiterführende ja aber dann kannst du
auch den den philosophischen es lesen
und und nicht zurückgreifen auf einen
verstehe ich finde ich mich zu viel
[Musik]